>> WE DON'T TELL YOU A LOT ABOUT
POLL MEMBERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNRELIABLE AND REALLY JUST A
SNAPSHOT BUT HOLY SMOKE,
JOE BIDEN'S POLL NUMBERS ARE
BAD, BORDER POLICIES, INFLATION,
THE DEBACLE IN AFGHANISTAN AND
IF THAT IS NOT ENOUGH, THE DAILY
MAIL SAYING THAT HE
COULD BE IMPLICATED IN AN FBI
INVESTIGATION, SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST AT FOX NEWS AND FOR GOOD
REASON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
NOT AN AGE QUESTION, A WISDOM
QUESTION.
AT THIS MOMENT, ACCORDING --
>> IT IS AN AGE QUESTION.
>> Tucker: 'S OF THE DAILY
MAIL SAYS THAT BIDEN MAY HAVE
FUNDED SOME OF HUNTER'S
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES AND
THEY SHARED BANK ACCOUNTS.
IF THAT IS TRUE THAT SOUNDS LIKE
A BIG DEAL.
IS IT?
>> IT WOULD BE A BIG DEAL IF IT
IS SHOWN THAT HUNTER'S BUSINESS
ACTIVITIES, SOME WHICH WERE VERY
QUESTIONABLE, WERE DOWN TO DO
HIS FATHER'S FINANCIAL --
BECAUSE CLEARLY HUNTER BIDEN
CROSSED ETHICAL LINES IN THE
ACTIVITIES HE ENGAGES IN AND
THERE WAS ALWAYS THIS CONFLICT
OF INTEREST OF HIM SERVING,
DOING BUSINESS IN UKRAINE WHEN
HIS FATHER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
POLICY RELATED TO UKRAINE.
THAT HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR A
LONG TIME, WE'VE ALL KNOWN THAT.
IF IT WERE TO COME OUT THAT
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF OR HIS
CAMPAIGN PROFITED FROM THAT IT
WOULD MOVE THE MATTER UP QUITE A
NOTCH AND ADD ONE MORE THING TO
THE REASONS WHY JOE BIDEN'S
POPULARITY RATING HAS BEEN
PLUMMETING AS YOU POINT OUT.
>> Tucker: I HATE TO SAY THIS
BUT GIVEN THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL LIKENING
PARENTS TO DOMESTIC TERRORISTS,
CAN WE BE CERTAIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WILL CONDUCT A FREE
AND FAIR INVESTIGATION?
>> NO.
IN A WORD, NO.
THE ONE THING THIS
MERRICK GARLAND HAS TURNED OUT
TO BE FOR ALL HIS REPUTATION AS
BEING A MAN WHO DESERVED A SEAT
ON THE SUPREME COURT, HE APPEARS
TO BE WEAK AS WATER WHEN IT
COMES TO UPHOLDING INDEPENDENCE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND KEEPING THEM OUT OF
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
INVESTIGATIONS.
THIS HAD THE FBI LOOKING INTO
PARENTS' MOTIVATIONS, SOMETHING
NO SENSIBLE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD EVER ALLOW HIMSELF TO BE
INVOLVED IN OR GAVE THE GREEN
LIGHT TO AND YET HE DID IT SO I
DON'T THINK WE CAN DEPEND ON
THAT AT ALL.
IT MIGHT DEPEND ON INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM OR INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM OF DEMOCRATS EVER
TAKE CONTROL OF BOTH HOUSES OF
CONGRESS.
>> Tucker: MAY BE
"THE NEW YORK POST" WILL REPORT
ON THE CONTENTS OF ITS -- OH,
WAIT.
THIS STORY WHICH FIRST LEARNED
ABOUT IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR, A
YEAR AGO WAS SQUELCHED
COMPLETELY BY THE MEDIA
TIGHTENS.
I WONDER IF WE CAN BE CERTAIN WE
WILL GET THE DETAILS THIS YEAR.
>> I WOULD THINK OF
"THE NEW YORK POST" COMES
FORWARD YOU WILL GET ANOTHER
STORY ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN.
I DRESSED IN HOPE AT LEAST THAT
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA OUTLETS
BEHAVED SO DISGRACEFULLY LAST
YEAR WHEN "THE NEW YORK POST"
BROKE THE OTHER STORY, TO PICK
UP THE STORY.
I WOULD NOT EXPECT, HOWEVER,
THAT THEY WOULD SIC THEIR
INVESTIGATIVE TEAMS ON THEM FROM
DAY-TO-DAY.
IT'S A LOT BETTER THAN NOTHING
WHICH IS WHAT WE GOT LAST YEAR.
THE POLITICALLY CORRUPT NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS.
>> Tucker: THEY WOULD HAVE TO
PULL A LOT OF GUYS OFF OF THE
QANON ARMY BEAT TO DO THAT.
YOU THINK THEY CAN?
>> [LAUGHS]
IT'S A SAD STATE OF AFFAIRS BUT
I THINK THERE IS ENOUGH NOISE
ABOUT THIS THAT THE WHOLE
COUNTRY WOULD BE ABLE TO HEAR
IT, AND A ABOUT IT.
THE BORDER SITUATION, WHICH WAS
IGNORED FOR MANY MONTHS BY
MAINSTREAM MEDIA OUTLETS FINALLY
BROKE THROUGH.
THESE THINGS CAN'T BE SUPPRESSED
FOREVER, AT LEAST ONE HOPES NOT.
>> Tucker: IN 20 SECONDS WHAT
EFFECTS DOES THIS HAVE ON THE
MIDTERMS WHICH ARE A YEAR FROM
NOW?
>> THE DISAPPROVAL OF JOE BIDEN
HURTS THIS PARTY AND THE
MIDTERMS AND THE PRESIDENT
BUSTER'S APPROVAL RATINGS AND
STANDING WITH THE PUBLIC,
ESPECIALLY A PRESIDENT'S FIRST
MIDTERM AFTER HE TAKES OFFICE IN
WHICH THE PRESIDENT'S PARTY
HISTORICALLY DOES BADLY.
THE OUTLOOK IN THE HOUSE IS VERY
POOR AND IT MIGHT SPILL OVER TO
THE SENATE AS WELL ALTHOUGH THE
MAP FAVORS DEMOCRATS BUT A BIG
WAVE ELECTION WOULD SWEEP THE
DEMOCRATS OUT A